just a few weeks ago the Navy admitted
for the first time that several UFO
videos were real meaning they show
actually area phenomenon that's so far
the Pentagon cannot explain now a UFO
investigations group says they have
found materials that could potentially
be physical evidence of UFOs Louise
Elizondo is director of special programs
at the to the stars Academy of Arts and
Science he also headed the Pentagon's
office for investigating UFO incidents
and it's the star of The History
Channel's unidentified he joins us to at
least thanks so much for coming on so
what is this material and why could it
shed light on the question of what UFOs
might be sure well our company over the
last year and a half has actually
obtained quite a bit of material and let
me first preface by saying some of that
material that's Providence is frankly
hearsay while other the Providence of
some of this material is has been
substantiated
and ultimately we're in the process of
analyzing this material at three
different levels we're looking at its
physical properties its chemical or if
you will molecular properties and then
ultimately its atomic properties and
it's really at that point we'll be able
to make some sort of definitive
conclusion keeping in mind that we still
have to follow the the scientific
process and methods and at the same time
have peer review so it's not just as
simple as coming out and saying hey look
what we found there's a lot of work that
still needs to be done I bet that's
right and of course you'll be challenged
as he as he ought to be challenged I
think quickly somewhat of course why do
you think this material might be
connected to UFOs well without getting
to a lot of detail right now because
it's it's it's frankly it's too
speculative for me at this point to say
why I think something at the end of the
day it's going to be what the analysis
tells us and if you have for example
interesting isotopic ratios that are not
normally found let's say on this planet
then you have to scratch your head in
either a it's been engineered that way
or be it came from somewhere else and
ultimately that's what we're trying to
find out so these are materials brought
to you by people who say this is at the
site of a UFO incident or a crash in
some cases yes again a fortune I can't
elaborate too much with some of these
individuals we do have write
non-disclosure agreements but it's
from from various sources both private
and governmental because that's saying I
hope that you'll come back as you get to
the bottom this we remain skeptical but
open-minded on this and all things with
great decision thank you so much me
Court absolutely thank you